t 4 Mmm, just like how the noodles do 4
, they're just bluffing class It's impossible for them to pass in this situation Hey, it
's all over I'm back in the waiting room
Can't you believe it?
[Music]
Early winter Lee Min-ho, from the family of Kutchan Day
Oh
Kutchan-cho, which is known as a heavy snowfall area even in Hokkaido, is a major potato production area
.
95% of the ingredient is actually potato electric wave saw
Snowfall action 6
First, pull out the baron potato and turn
to face the hook.
I don't have enough flour,
but I'll use potato starch instead.
It works perfectly and
you get a chewy dough full of starch
.
I procured the ingredients and
created a masterpiece that could make a beautiful woman come.
I'll help
you out
Ping spends money
It might be a good idea In the
snow
, there's more work to do besides making noodles, so don't be late.
I know the radar